I'm joined today by Corey Duggan who's
professor of sociology at Stone Hill
College and author of the new book kill
it - save it Corey this concept of kill
it - save it it's a concept that in
politics we've heard sort of for
different reasons and in different ways
from the political left and the
political right but speaking generally
what's that concept mean kill it - save
it
well the way I use it in the book is to
explain the current trend towards trying
to dismantle the public sector and the
public infrastructure and in essence the
public good all under the guise of
reform and so the reform narrative and I
think today today or tomorrow we'll find
out about the Republican health care
plan but the idea of essentially
dismantling public support for public
health and public welfare privatizing it
in essence destroying it under the guise
of trying to save it or reform it yeah
and that seems to be I mean would you
agree that that's more of a right-wing
perspective on kill it to save it well I
think that the right wing has really
crystallized this this paradigm and I
think that the you know Donald Trump has
really brought to bear kind of almost
every one and the worst elements what
kill it - save it represent but it's
probably important to note that I wrote
the book assuming Hillary Clinton was
going to be the next president and the
fact that the Democratic Party has
embraced neoliberalism and neoliberalism
is really the foundation of Killah to
save it then I would suggest that it's
not just a right-wing agenda to
privatize the public sector but the
right wing is probably the most
voracious and and in fact the most
successful of doing it the sort of other
more left-wing version of kill it to
save it and I know that this isn't what
the book is about but you're sort of to
put it out there would be the idea that
that we heard from some we actually have
heard it in the lead-up to a number of
presidential elections and sometimes
it's a response to what you're pointing
to as the NiO live
tendencies of the moderate and
mainstream Democratic Party today this
idea of I'm going to vote for whether
it's Ralph Nader
or Jill Stein or whoever even if it
leads to or helps a Republican become
elected president because I support a
total breakdown of order with the longer
term goal of eventually improving
circumstances when everybody realizes
how bad of an idea it is what's your
thought on that I mean that's my idea of
the left wing kill it to save it right I
have to say I think it's a kind of
narrow conception of it and then I'd say
these three things I think I can
remember them all one is that I don't
know all that many leftist so though
there might be some sectarian Maoists
and other folks who really believe the
total breakdown of societies what's
necessary to rebuild it maybe some
anarcho-syndicalist are still out there
hoping for the ashes of the old but that
kind of Neolithic tendency I don't think
is what is behind most of the left wing
of the Democratic Party and the left who
won't vote for the Democratic Party
I would suggest there's also a
principled reason to support other
candidates and that the practicality or
pragmatism that's behind I think the
image that you put forth about that
level of kill to save it on the Left
doesn't hold water in for the same
reasons that I was suggesting that the
Democratic embrace of neoliberalism has
actually brought us Donald Trump I don't
I don't think that the inability of the
Democrats to come up with any actual Pro
public welfare and critical of
capitalist agenda suggests that you know
voting for the Clintons and the Obamas
and the even worse to the right-wing
Democrats has actually gotten us
anywhere but further to the right so I
think there's a there's a there's a
value ethical question about why people
do vote for candidates but I think
there's even a strategical practical
error in that conception of voting for
Democrats who may not be as bad as seem
as bad as the Republicans but
who we should be supporting if we're
really progressive so to dig into more
of the specifics that we're talking
about here why do so many people but
cheer or support candidates or policies
that are going to actually not be great
for them personally but also more
broadly sort of hurt democracy as we
know it as a sort of the the most
representative possible form of
democracy we saw this in 2010 with the
Tea Party by and large supporting
candidates whose policies would benefit
them if they one day became rich which
of course statistically most of them
never ever will there's many many
examples of this I mean why do people do
that
well in the book I suggest there's a
kind of ideology that's been hardwired
over the last 50 years but particularly
during the Reagan administration and
really the rise of neoliberalism that's
combined what I call hyper individualism
this notion of we are best when we are
most free and we're most free when we
are unrestrained by government programs
unburdened by public responsibilities
give us all of our money back we don't
want to pay taxes because the government
doesn't know what to do that I know what
to do with it and then linking eiper
individualism with a kind of corporate a
dominant way of thinking that suggests
you know whatever's good for
corporations is clearly good for us and
so while there are lots of
contradictions in those two things fused
together it means that people
consistently vote against their best
interests because they don't have any
faith or belief in the public sector
anymore but of course as individuals we
can't build roads and we can't fix
bridges and we can't improve our
educational system and we could go on
and on down the line but the best this
country and really the world has ever
had to offer people was when we
recognized our mutual interests or
mutual self-interest and the need for us
as people to come together to build the
large things that societies need and
since you
Ronald Reagan I mean there's definitely
some aspect of the importance of myths
that that enter people's minds when they
conceptualized either the role of
government or welfare programs or
whatever poverty for example I mean with
Reagan there was this welfare queen who
drove a Cadillac I mean I don't even
remember the specifics of it at this
point
more broadly there's this idea that oh
poor people are the only source
responsible for their own poverty
there's nothing systemic at all that we
can point to or class mobility or
whatever the case may be and these myths
have been pretty successfully been
perpetrated and repeated over the last
many decades haven't they
that's right and they are a sort of the
big lie in the sense that the more often
they're repeated the more likely they
are that people will believe them and I
do think it's really hard especially
this particular historical juncture for
a lot of people in the United States
Americans and particularly white
Americans to kind of think about the
historical and structural ways in which
working people people of color have been
oppressed and discriminated again and I
actually just wrote a piece in which
looking at a case here in Massachusetts
where the Massachusetts Supreme Court
actually found that it was legal and one
should not in fact prejudice in court
against African American men who flee
from the police during questioning or
were being asked to stop because because
racial profiling has reached such a
degree in places like Boston and
Baltimore in Ferguson and actually you
could go through every state and every
city in the country that actually had
studied this issue the Department of
Justice has done a number of these
studies and find that racial profiling
is alive and well and so brilliant and
so detrimental particularly to
african-american men that it is in fact
justifiable for them to flee this is
what the Supreme Court of Massachusetts
found and so the idea that we have still
hardwired streams of races
and the streams of class exploitation
should come as no surprise big surprise
is that we are so many people are so
happy to have the entitlement of race
the entitlement of being white that
they'll also try to ignore that it
actually still exists and the same is
true with class exploitation
you know Ronald Reagan successfully
started the trend towards dismantling
unions and delegitimizing unions when
collective bargaining and collective
power among workers was really what the
middle class was built off we've been
speaking about the book kill it to save
it whose author has been talking to us
Cory
Dogen professor of sociology at Stone
Hill College I highly recommend the book
so great talking to you about this today
thank you so much David